I'm raising three young daughters oh I  teach them to be strong independent  women people are building up self-esteem  in their kids in the wrong [ __ ] such a  challenge out there and it goes both  boys and girls whatever you positively  reinforce as them doing good is 100 the  framework of where their self-esteem  will sit if you really want this for  them for the three of them it's gonna be  what you're clapping for that's what  she's gonna really look for when my kids  show compassion and empathy I like throw  a fiesta because I I think that's going  to be an epic thing for them to be  awesome at me it's not the thing that  you're gonna tear down that they're  gonna be it's gonna be the thing that  you build up